and one such prey of the
media of these media
tactics was
myself 8 months
back in the fourth week of June
2010 I was supposed to give a series of
talk in
UK I was supposed to give a talk in the
v arena in W London in LG Arena NC
Birmingham as well as Sheffield arena in
Sheffield all these venues had a
capacity of 10 to
15,000 people and these are prestigious
venues just 3 weeks before my lecture
tour there was an article which came in
one of the leading newspaper that Sunday
Times Sunday times it gave an article
Muslim preacher of hate let into Britain
and this article it gave portions of my
speeches which were either quoted out of
context or they were misquoted and it
portrayed me as a preacher of Fate a
person who promotes
terrorism and the next couple of days
the same article was picked up rehashed
and reprinted in many of the newspapers
of UK not only newspapers of UK but
newspapers internationally including the
newspapers of
India
unfortunately these
articles
inspired the h Secretary of UK teram to
pass an exclusion order on the 16th of
June
2010 after reading these articles and
hearing some clips from the YouTube
which were again either out of
context and there were portions which
were manipulated based on these YouTube
clips and the media report the Home
Secretary of UK on 16th of June 2010 she
passed an exclusion order against me and
the next day 17th of June the deputy
High Commissioner of Britain in Bombay
on the 17th of June they revoked and
canceled my Visa I had a valid 5 years
multiple entry visa to UK which was
issued on the 15th of July 2008 valid
till 15th of July 2013 I've been coming
to UK since the past 20 years I've come
several times and for lecture to other
several times I had a valid multiple
entry 5 years Visa which had come twice
before in 2008 2009 which was cancelled
without giving me a fair hearing I think
this is an attack on freedom of
expression as well as on human
rights Charles
far who is the director general of the
office of security and counter terrorism
he was not in favor of this exclusion
order and he wanted me to reach to those
Muslims who he felt the government could
not
reach but the Home Secretary ignoring
the advice of her senior more security
adviser she went ahead with the
exclusion order and later on a few weeks
later she even suspended one of the
advisers under Charles far who supported
me I personally have more faith in the
Judiciary System rather than the
political system of my country India as
well as the country of
UK we did a judicial
review and took it to the high court
though the Home Secretary said I have no
right to file under human rights because
I'm a non-uk citizen Justice granston
said and he reviewed it and he said that
he can file a case and he passed a
judgment and said that the first three
decisions of the Home Secretary on 16th
of June 17th of June and the 27th of
June all three were unlawful but however
later on in the month of August 2010
when they gave additional
information he said that this is lawful
which is not
logical I have faith in the Judiciary
System we have filed for an appeal
against the last judgment of the high
court and I full faith that inshallah
very shortly this exclusion order would
be reversed by the court of
appeal I hope in future I may have the
chance to meet the Home Secretary tame
personally and explain to her the
peaceful Message of Islam and remove any
misconception about Islam or any of my
lecture that she may have I would have
personally preferred to come personally
in the Oxford Union and give this talk
and have a lively question translation
rather than the satellite
last month i' had gone to France I was
in
Paris we had a board meeting of our
trust Islam Foundation International
which is based in UK as well as
universal broadcast limited because I
could not come to UK I called the board
members to Paris and I was shocked
normally the world feels that France is
more strict against Islam than UK but
when I applied for Visa I got it within
1 hour
and we had the board meeting there I
prefer heading it in UK but because of
the exclusion order which I feel the
court of appeal very shortly will
reverse it and though the world may
think that because of the exclusion
order it is an attack on freedom of
expression but I would like to thank the
Oxford Union that even though an
exclusion order has been passed on me
yet they permitted this debate or this
lecture for the question question answer
session I would like to thank doxford
Union especially the president Mr James
langman for being bold and agreeing to
have this
lecture the Oxford Union may or may not
agree with my
speech they may like my talk or may not
like my talk what I appreciate is that
they are really people who promote
freedom of expression I would like to
conclude my speech by giving a message
peace is the only solution for the
problems of
humanity many nations many countries
have
armies they have got military they have
got Navy theyve got Air Force some
countries have weapons of mass
destruction some have nuclear weapons
believe me all these are not the
solution for the problems of humanity
the only solution according to me for
the problems of humanity is
peace there may be
differences there are differences in
culture there are differences in
languages there are differences in color
there's difference of society
irrespective of the differences one
common factor amongst all human being of
the world is that all want peace
according to me peace is the only
solution for the problems of
humanity I said at the starting of my
talk Islam is derived from the Arabic
word Salam which means
peace and this word Salam is mentioned
in the Quran no less than 43 times and
along with its
derivatives it's mentioned no less than
143 times Salam peace is mentioned in
the Quran no less than 143
times and I started my talk by greeting
all of you assalam which means peace be
on all of you the Quran says in Surah
Yassin chapter number 36
verse number 58 that peace is a
salutation from the Lord who is the most
merciful one of the attributes of
almighty God is ass Salam the source of
peace Quran says in Surah alash chapter
59 verse number 23 it refers to Allah
almighty God as ass Salam the source of
peace Quran says in Sur ma 5 verse
number 16 that almighty God guides those
people who come towards him toward peace
and safety and takes them out of
Darkness into light that's the reason
every chapter of the Glorious Quran
there are 114 chapters in the Quran
every chapter except nine starts with
the beautiful
formula in the name of Allah almighty
God the most merciful the most
gracious according to me peace is the
only solution for Humanity and I am a
person who spread spreads peace my
mission is to spread peace and as many
may be
aware that I started a Global Peace TV
network about 5 years before in January
2006 in January
2006 I launched the peace TV in English
2 and a half years later in 2008 peace
TV Udu and inshallah in the next couple
of months in April
2011 we will launch the PE TV banga
today peace tv English is the largest
washed Islamic Satellite channel in the
world it has a viewership of more than
100 million out of which more than 25%
are non-muslim even if I'm able to
convince one human being irrespective
whether he a Muslim or non-muslim and
prevent him from killing one innocent
human being I feel I would have saved
the whole of
humankind peace is the only solution my
message is only of peace my mission is
to spread peace I would like to end my
talk with the quotation of Dr Adam
Pearson Dr Adam Pearson said people
worry that one day nuclear weaponry will
fall in the hands of the Arabs they fail
to realize that the Islamic bomb the
bomb of Peace has already been dropped
it fell the day Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was born ald
[Applause]
okay ladies and gentlemen I will now
like to ask some of you to Signal your
intention to ask questions to Dr Nike
the way in which we're going to do this
is if you will signal your intention to
me we will then try and go up to the
microphone on the podium in groups of
five please stand at the podium deliver
your question and wait at the podium
until you have received your answer sir
then return to your seat so for the
first five can I get Goldberg Mr Bella
please stand start off with those three
queuing signal your
intention and add to the queue after
they come down Dr Nik thank you very
much for your talk the question I have
is you profess to be a man of Peace
you've spoken very eloquently about the
idea of peace and Islam peces written in
front of your microphone as you stand
there and I agree with you in many
senses but my question is why then is
your message still seen as so
controversial why are there figures
within the Islamic World why are there
fellow Islamic clerics who see your
message and still believe that you are
wrong why you you've claimed that the
Home Secretary has banned you from this
country because of a sort of media
conspiracy but why is there a broader
sense of discontent with your message
the brother asked a very good question
that why if I'm a man of peace and I
speak about peace some people are
against me some Muslims some non-muslims
Home Secretary brother you have to
understand that any person who's popular
they're bound to be people are against
him irrespective whether the popular
person is doing good work or bad work
and the best example I can give you that
today according to Michael H har he
wrote a book saying the 100 most
influential people in the world history
though he's a Christian he put number
one most influential human being as
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him today
do you know though Muslims consider him
to be the most important and the most
influential person in history there are
many non-muslims who think the same but
today if you analyze the maximum books
written against any human being on the
face of the Earth it is Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him the second person he
named in his list was Isaac Newton but
because he's not a common man for common
human being he's a scientist the third
person on his list was Jesus Christ
peace be upon him if we analyze today
the second person in human history who
has Max books written against him it is
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him based on
this argument do we have to agree that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
Prophet Jesus peace be upon him they
were not good what we have to realize
when a person gets popular there are
bound to be people against him and
according to the home Department of UK
when I had come in the year 2009 I was
informed by reliable sources that
according to the home Department of UK
the most popular Islamic Satellite
channel in the world is peace TV and the
most watched Islamic Satellite channel
in UK is also peace TV not only is it
watched by Muslims but even watched by
non-muslims the same report said that
the most popular Islamic speaker in the
world is Dr Zakir Nik and the most
popular Islamic speaker in UK is also Dr
Nik that's the reason the home
Department was requesting me that can I
reach out to those Muslims which the UK
government cannot but now because of the
change of government what I feel it was
more of a political move rather than a
legal move and as maybe they wanted
someone popular so that they could pass
the message that we are tough against
Muslims and that the reason what we feel
that we have more faith in the judicial
system rather than the political system
I think it was mainly because of
popularity and it was mainly a political
move rather than a legal move and
inshallah God willing we feel that this
exclusion order would be reversed by the
court of appeal
hopefully thank
you my name I'm a I'm a lawyer a
historian and also a
theologian you gave a very excellent
exposition of uh the Quran and
Islam but uh Judaism Christianity and
Islam
uh all abrahamic
Faith a Jew could have said the same
thing all this almost the same things
have you said by quoting uh the Quran
sorry it's quoting the the Torah and the
talad a Christian could have said almost
everything you said by quoting both the
Old Testament and the New
Testament
and I do not know whether we should be
trying to say one religion is Superior
or more truthful than another and if we
do go down that line what does that lead
to uh that's what led to the Crusades
Etc you mentioned about Justice and
peace of course the Christian Bible
mentions more there are more verses
about Justice and peace than there are
about the hor Holy Spirit and of course
Christians were pacifist until
313 when
so what is the difference between what
you are saying and Judaism and
Christianity and what would that lead to
but a good question and I do agree with
him that if you read the books of
Judaism the books of Christianity you
will find verses of Peace never in my
lecture ever did I say that any religion
is against peace or any religion is in
favor of terrorism I always said all
religions are against terrorism what I
made one statement in my speech that the
verse of the Quran chapter 5 verse
number 32 this verse which is so
emphatic I do not find a similar verse
in any of the scripture because I'm a
student of comparative religion saying
that if you kill one innocent human
being it is as though you have killed
the whole of humanity and if you save
one innocent human being it is as though
you have saved the whole of humanity it
was only one verse that generally I do
agree that most of the religions almost
all they speak about peace that's the
reason Jesus Christ peace be upon him if
you read the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36 when he goes
to theupper room he says when he wishes
Apostles shalam alikum which means same
peace be upon you in Hebrew so the
greetings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him too when he met the people wasalam
alaykum which meant same in Arabic
assalam alaykum may peace be on you
regarding you seeing that one religion
superior to the other religion I believe
almighty God sent only one religion he
has not sent different religions what
the Quran says he has made human beings
into different tribes different colors
different languages so that they may
recognize each other not they might
despise each other the only religion
that God has sent to all his Messengers
whether it be Moses whether it be Jesus
peace be upon Him Moses peace be upon
Him Muhammad peace be upon it was to
submit the will to almighty God I
believe all these Messengers right from
Adam Noah Moses Jesus Muhammad peace be
upon them all all of them bought the
same message that believe in one God and
worship him alone and only him and
submit your will to that almighty God
hope that answerers the question
good afternoon Dr Nik um my name's Izzy
westrey I'm the secretary here at the
Oxford Union I have a very short
question to ask um you talk about the
hijab being something that served to
protect a woman surely it's it's
extremely patronizing and degrading to
prevent a woman from making that
decision for herself how could you
answer
that what's the question sister I said
in your speech you talk about the hijab
being something that serves to protect a
woman but how is it not extremely
patronizing and degrading and not
allowing the woman to make that decision
herself s POS a very good question that
when I say that hijab is required for a
woman isn't it not degrading for the
woman to pize it isn't it degrading if
you read the Quran the Quran and Islam
has prescribed hijab that means the
woman should be covered the only part
that can be seen are the face and the
hands up to the wrist this this is for
the modesty and it is not only mentioned
in the Quran it is also mentioned in the
bible if you read the Bible in the 1
Timothy chapter number two verse number
n it says that women should be dressed
up with
shamefacedness they should be Dred up
with sobriety and should not wear
braided hair or gold or pearls it's
further mentioned in the First
Corinthians chapter number 11 verse
number five six the woman that does not
cover a head then she dishonors a head a
head should be shaved off anyway I don't
agree with this I'm just quoting you
from the Bible same way if you go to The
Vedas it says that the woman should
cover the head so all the religious
scriptures they talk about the wom
covering their head it is for modesty it
is not to degrade the woman and if you
analyze there was allegation made
against me saying that Dr Zak Nik says
that if they don't wear hijab you know
that if you wear western clothes there
are chances the women will be raped it
is a misquotation again what I said that
if women were revealing clothes they
have more chances of being raped what I
was doing the same Newspaper Sunday time
which spoke against me one year before
on the march of 9th 2009 Sunday time
sced an article in Britain one out of
seven feel that the woman who we sexy
revealing clothes she should be hit I'm
sorry I don't agree with it this is the
statistics that was given in the Sunday
Times on the 9th of March 2009 that in
Britain one out of seven britishers
believe that the women who were
revealing and sexy clothes should be hit
I disagree with this furthermore one
more article came in 2005 in the same
Newspaper Sunday times it said that 26%
of the britishers they feel that wearing
revealing clothes is partially or
totally responsible for the rape so what
I say that the more modest you are
dressed up you are respected more so
Islam has prescribed the modest hijab
for the woman not to degrade her but to
uplift her I do agree there may be
cultural differences Islam cannot force
anyone to adopt it there are cultural
differences for example I'll give you an
example that some societies what they
feel that even looking at a woman is a
modest some societies feel looking is no
problem but touching a woman is a modest
some of the societies feel shaking hand
is no problem some societies feel
kissing no problem some societies feel
doing anything as long as both agree is
no problem different societies and
different cultures have got different
rules and regulations when I went to
America while I was giving a talk one of
the American told me you Eastern woman
you IM modest I was shocked so I said
why you call the Eastern woman immodest
he told me you Eastern women you expose
your
belly so in America and Western Country
exposing belly is IM modesty in India
exposing belly is not immodesty wearing
shorts is immodesty so what have realize
sister there's different culture there's
different system Islam cannot force
anyone to adopt it's clearly mentioned
in the Quran in Bak number 2 verse
number
256 there's no compulsion religion but
if some women want to adopt the hijab
because they feel modest and they feel
respected I feel no other women should
disagree and when I've been to UK I've
seen hundreds and thousands of women who
do cover their hair and who feel that
they uplifted because of this modesty
hope that answer the
[Applause]
question good evening Dr
zik my name is Dr Ramsey from
Oxford uh Ambassador V University peace
Federation and one of the member of the
Muslim Council of
Britain I would like to say you are
doing an excellent job God bless
you now my
question Dr
zakai in your opinion is islamophobia a
real
phenomenon and if
so how how do you suggest it can be
tackled does the responsibility lie with
the Muslim
Community or should Western Society be
doing more to breach this barrier of
fear I'm talking about the fear all
phobias are fear fear of unknown thank
you the brother ask a very good question
that is islamophobia a real phenomenon
how should it be tackled is it the
responsibility of the Muslim Community
to do it yes there is islamophobia
especially in this 21st century and as I
mentioned in my speech I believe one of
the major reason for this islamophobia
is the media and I said in my speech
that the media spreads several
misconceptions about this religion of
Islam I do agree it is the duty of us
Muslims that we should spread the true
teachings of Islam I'm aware that there
are black sheep in the Muslim Community
I'm not saying all Muslims are 100%
Pious all are good there are black sheep
in every Community including Muslims
what does the media do they pick up the
blackship of the Muslim Community and
they portray on the media as though
they're exemplary Muslims what we have
to do is we have to portray the right
teachings of Quran and the sayings of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
and if any Muslim is involved in doing
acts which are against the of Islam
which are acts of terrorism killing of
innocent human beings it is the duty of
us Muslims that we should tell such
people it is Haram there are some people
who are being
misguided and they have being
brainwashed into saying that killing
innocent human beings is part of Islam
you'll get reward it's our duty as the
mainstream Muslims to try and convey the
right message of Islam and prevent such
Muslims from being misguided that's
Point number one point number two it's a
duty to tell the government of the
country where you're living that Islam
is a peaceful religion and what I
believe that Muslims should be part of
the solution they should not be part of
the problem the government should not
think that Muslims are part of the
problem they should think Muslims are
part of the solution and that the advice
I even give to the police of India and
the police of Bombay and I interact with
the police force very often and I tell
them that you should take the Muslims in
confidence and the best is to have an
interaction I have addressed many police
officers from very different countries
and we should try and have a question
answer session and remove the
misconceptions in their minds and prove
to them that Islam is one of the most
tolerant religions it's a peaceful
religion and if you know the teaching of
Islam surely the least person that you
have to fear is a true Muslim I'm not
talking about the black sheep of the
Muslim Community hope that ansers the
question Dr Nike I'm Yasmin I'm a
student at the University and my
question is sort of related to the last
question um you talked about you wanted
to come to the UK because you wanted to
reach out to Muslims who you felt that
the government were not able to reach
out to and I wondered why in your
opinion you felt that the government
were failing in this way to reach out to
Muslims in Britain thank you s as a
question that I wanted to come to UK to
reach out to those Muslims who the
government could not reach out sister
there's a slight confusion I said
Charles far the director general of the
office of security and counter terrorism
felt that I could reach out to those
Muslims who the government could not
reach out to he felt that not me and I
think again because of the information
which the home department has that peace
TV is the most popular Islamic Satellite
channel in UK watched by the Muslims as
well as the non-muslims and the most
popular speaker according to the home
Department not according to me according
to the home department is Dr zakin n so
I repeated what he thought that I could
reach better maybe he thinks that my
speeches have influenced and he may have
read my speeches in context that's the
reason
he was not in favor of the Home
Secretary that she passed the exclusion
order hope that answerers the question
do you think that he has a point do you
think that um in some sense the
government are failing to reach out to
Muslims in prison though if you ask my
opinion that do I agree with the
thoughts of Charles far that the
government is failing out yes I do agree
with him I do agree because as I said in
my earlier answer that the government
should not think that musl Muslims are
part of the problem the government
should think that Muslims are part of
the solution because a Muslim there are
many Muslims who are British citizens
and it's the duty of every Muslim to
follow all the laws of the country
staying in as long as the law does not
force him to do something which is PRI
in the religion or prevents him from
doing something which is compens in
religion as far as India is concerned I
do not know of any rule or any law in
the Constitution which forces a Muslim
in India to do something which is
prohibited neither does it prevent me
from doing something which is compulsory
so I am a practicing Muslim and I'm
Proud to be an Indian so I'm proud to be
an Indian Muslim similarly there are
many britishers who I feel may be
feeling the same they may be Muslims and
they may be following the laws of the
country so they British Muslims so I
feel that the government should take in
confidence and what they should do that
they should see to it that this
maligning by the media should stop and
the best example best example is myself
I mean there are many there are 100
million viewers of peach TV and there
are millions of people who tell that I'm
the Ambassador for peace they say I'm a
peaceful person there are many heads of
states of several foreign countries many
they have called me at the state guest
so do you mean to say all these heads of
states of several countries the
president the prime minister the king
the shik they meet me they have done do
you mean to say they're meeting a person
who is promoting terrorism a person who
spreads hate so what I'm seeing that
this is all again manipulated by the
media so the government should not fall
prey to the media and take any decision
hly what they should do they should give
a chance for the person to clarify and
then I'm sure that most of the
misconceptions will be removed and I'm
sure that UK would be a more peaceful
country to live in hope that the
[Applause]
question for this evening due to the
limitation of the satellite link however
I would ask you now to join with me in
thanking Dr Knight for his speech and
pass it back to peace TV to finish the
evening and with that ladies and
gentlemen I remain James sangman and
your president thank you
[Applause]
I would like to thank the Oxford Union
especially the president of the Oxford
Union Mr Jame langman for making this
event possible and I near
appreciate with the way they invited me
for this talk and at least now the
people of UK can really see a live
telecast that I'm a person who gives the
message of Peace in a live telecast
there is no editing there's no
manipulation you can have more faith in
these live telecast rather than
clippings from YouTube which can be
manipulated I would like to thank the
members of the Oxford Union once again
and I hope very shortly once the
exclusion order is reversed I would like
to personally come to the Oxford Union
and meet the members of the Oxford
thank you very
[Applause]
much
world can we SP a little
jce can we SP little
peace
for children of oh people of the world
can we SP it
alone can we SP little
pray
for the children of
[Music]
War children